jump boss this is the big one
debuted on the Microsoft stage this spin
is an anime fighters dream look at
what's going on here
and the roster from what I'm told is
gonna be increased
Lamport has a commitment to this game
you know as far as the anime scene this
is like a dream come true I mean the
best equivalent for those who are not
into enemy that have been that's
probably me too I'm not a hardcore anime
guy it's just literally like almost like
imagine if every of Marvel's DC had all
their best characters better games and
just got it going
special actions
[Music]
so apparently from what I've been told
from nan Cola I jump horse things like
all the realities of what would happen
if the realities kind of merged together
and will be this jump of his jump horse
team they're kind of like they're doing
what they're kind of protected so that
from my understanding it's like the
basic storyline that kind of bit
and it's just so over-the-top our style
is fantastic
we got your boy right there and the
Super's in this entire right now in
saint
let's go
so a lot of three big three actions on
we get busy now
[Music]
we seen the switch out right now
finished
so when it is I seem to be everybody's
free man right now
[Music]
nameless dead man in the fantastics jump
horse in the building
got a little Dragonball comment going on
character choices
see if we can get a difference to
everybody
so we got women's awakened techniques
accident to come when they can go
explint so we've got the okay art so and
hey we got a little bit of some more
control action just
to see what it do
legal authority death
[Music]
you must get
hmm
oh I just love the pool with the top
stylist on stylisation and again but
he's just sold anime you know I mean
it's just so over the top and I think
that's what the appeal is you don't mean
to sit and look at things like that the
cinematics you just really get you into
the emotional aspect of the character
that you want to get for the record on a
plane
someone took me to a bridge so that you
can do that get your bridge going on in
this
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
so you got your abilities right there
what so now
again that work hi he's failing it he's
digging it he's digging it no doubt
there it is man jump horse coming Seoul
Khan so bad they've got another one yeah